okay real quick a viewer let's call him
Jimmy to protect his identity that's not
his real name but I want to protect his
identity because of where he works Jimmy
wrote in to tell us that at his place of
employment the New York State Capitol
building the David Pakman show website
is blocked but Alex Jones's Infowars
website is allowed at the New York State
Capitol building this is an email i
received from quote jimmy who said hey
david check it out you're blocked at the
New York State Capitol I like to listen
to the show at work but unfortunately
the show has been blocked by our IT
department not sure why YouTube is
available secular talk is available even
steven Crowder's web site is available i
heart radio was blocked but not Sirius
XM or Infowars not sure what the
standard could possibly be thought it
was an interesting thing to point out
thankfully I have unlimited data so I
can just listen on my cell and he sent a
picture also pointing out that when
trying to access david pakman.com he
gets a message saying that this category
is not allowed because it is streaming
media if the barometer is streaming
media web sites are blocked
how could you tube not be blocked what
what is a bigger streaming media website
then going on YouTube and streaming
endless gigabytes of high-definition
video but yet david pakman.com is
blocked right and i spoke to our
analytics department and they estimate
that had we not been blocked at the new
york state capitol the channel would
have had over had overall maybe a
billion two billion more view i read the
same thing yeah that's merely because
there's such a demand for the david
pakman show at the new york state
capitol building that were it not for
that we would already have our million
subscriber plaque from youtube up on the
wall instead of just a hundred thousand
subscriber plaque so yeah i don't know
what the logic is it's very odd i want
to resist becoming conspiratorial but i
wonder if there is some political
motivation taking place in terms of what
websites are and are
blocked at the New York State Capitol
building am I going too far maybe Pat
and waiting in two waters where I like
evidence I think this is grounds for
investigation at least I mean we can't
really jump to any conclusions you know
but I think it's reason for concern I
find it odd I find it really odd that
we're blocked because we're screening
media but YouTube's not blocked but yet
Infowars
and Steven Crowder's website are allowed
at the New York State Capitol building
very very strange we'll take a break
maybe we'll find out more about that
we will come back and I have sort of
some good news about what's going on in
the fight for net neutrality